- One of my favorite quotes,
and I have it framed on the
mantelpiece in our house,
they all see it, they all know
it, is from Jonathan Swift.
Who said, "May you live
all the days of your life."
Live every day.
Live all the days of your life.
That's what matters.
Getting the most out of
life, while you're alive.
But get up and do things.
Accomplish something.
Make the world a little
better, every day if you can,
in some small way or other.
Help other people who need help.
Be kind.
Have empathy.
Put yourself in the other person's place.
And try not ever to be boring.
(audience laughs)
It's not fair to be boring!
It's unkind to your
friends or your family.